- And then you can open it,
and there's vagina stuff there.
(laughs) I don't wanna
talk about it anymore.
(light music)
- My experience with vaginas has been
mostly just
sex
with them.
- So I'm gay, which means my experience
with female anatomy comes exclusively
from my one year of high school anatomy.
- In high school I was
very scared of vaginas.
- I think I could get the general shape.
- And I don't know how well I know
the intricate vagina stuff.
- I don't really know what
a proper vagina looks like,
much less how to draw one.
- Isn't a vagina just like an
inverted penis or something?
I've never said vagina
so many times in my life.
- All right, let's try and draw this.
- What is this!
- And draw another shape like this.
- Like something up here maybe.
- What the fuck?
- Something should go here.
This feels too blank
for any type of genital.
(popping)
- I think the vaginal
opening is in the middle.
(buzzing)
- That is where the penis goes for sex.
(bell ringing)
- Like this?
Nah it's never, I don't
think it's ever that big.
If it is
that's cool too.
(popping)
- Labia majora
(bell ringing)
- Is that labia majora?
That's the clitoris, right?
(buzzing)
(popping)
- That's these, these inner
lips.
(bell ringing)
Is that right, the term?
- That's on the inside.
(bell ringing)
That's the line I drew
near the labia minora.
- Oh my fuck.
There's a labia minora?
What is this, Hanukkah?
(buzzing)
(popping)
- Then the clitoris
is this little man in the canoe up there.
(bell ringing)
- That's this one at the top.
Right?
(bell ringing)
(popping)
- Wouldn't that be the vagina?
(buzzing)
- I think that's at the bottom.
- We're just gonna say a
little hole right here.
(bell ringing)
(popping)
- Mom's pubis.
- Mons.
- I don't know if I wanna talk about
my mom's pubis right now, okay.
- Is that right?
(buzzing)
(bell ringing)
(popping)
- Right there.
(bell ringing)
- I think the anus is at the bottom.
- That's the anus.
(bell ringing)
I got some stuff.
(light music)
Whoa, that's a graphic
picture right there.
(laughing)
- Yes, I think the holes were misplaced.
- Oh my God, there's two flaps.
- The scale's a little
off, this is a huge vagina.
- It's like you gotta open it up like,
like a lettuce.
- I feel like people are
gonna say guys have no idea
what a vagina actually looks like.
- This has definitely changed the way
that I look at vaginas now.
I'm like,
I'm like kind of in awe.
- There's babies, there's orgasms.
Vaginas do a lot, we should respect that.
- Uh, good job vagina like,
good on you, you look cool.
You're an intricate organ
and it's impressive.
- Vaginas are complicated,
but they're important.
That's how we are all here,
so I guess it makes sense
to learn more about them.
- Vagina, vagina, vagina, it's vagina man.
Okay, we've gotten past
it, I can say vagina now.
It's out of my system.
Vagina.
Vagina, vagina.
(swooping)
(creaking)
Vagina.